[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
they ought to make the day the time
changes the first day of summer what
well it's eight o'clock and it's still
light a lot of good the extra daylight
does us now we've still got a three-hour
drive back we're not gonna be home until
after midnight well if it really bugged
you Johnny you wouldn't do it you think
I want to blow Sunday on a scene like
this you know I figure we're either
gonna have to move mother out here or
move the grave into Pittsburgh she can't
make a trip like this oh god she can't
that candy left no weird this thing we
still remember I don't you know I don't
even remember what the man looks like
Johnny it takes you five minutes yeah
five minutes to put the wreath on the
grave in six hours to drive back and
forth mother wants to remember so we
trot 200 miles into the country and she
stays at home well we're here John all
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing wrong with a radio mr. Vila
station which row is it in
[Music]
[Music]
well there's no one around
it's late you've gotten up earlier
oh look I already lost an hours sleep at
the time change
I think you complain just to hear
yourself talk there it is
[Music]
I wonder what happened to the one from
last year each year we spend good money
on these things we come out here and the
one from last year is gone well the
flowers die and the caretaker or
somebody takes them away yeah a little
spit and polish you can clean this up
sell it next year wonder how many times
we bought the same one
[Music]
hey come on barb church was this morning
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey I mean praying's for church huh come
on I haven't seen you in church lately
well there's not much sense in my going
to church do you remember one time when
we were small we were out here it was
from right over there I jumped out at
you from behind the tree and grandpa got
all excited he shook his fist at me and
he said boy you'll be damned to hell
remember that right over there well you
used to really be scared here Johnny
you're still afraid stop it now I mean
it
they're coming to get you Barbra
stop it you're ignorant they're coming
for you Barbra
stop it you're acting like a child
they're coming for you
look there comes one of them now you'll
hear you here he comes now I'm getting
out of here Johnny
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes all right
don't worry about him I can have been
happy be a lot more of them as soon as
they find out about us truck is out of
gas
this pump out here is locked is there a
key we can try to get out if we can get
some gas is there a key
I suppose you've tried this
do you live here
[Applause]
jeez
we've got to get out of here we have to
get with us and other people maybe we
better take some food I'll see if I can
find some food
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening what's happening
[Music]
[Music]
two of them there two of them out there
have you seen any more around here I can
take care of those two I I know you are
afraid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know we're in here now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't look at it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why don't you see if you can find some
wood some boards something there by the
fireplace something we can nail this
place up look I know you're afraid I'm
afraid too but we have to try to board
the house up together now I'm going to
board up the windows and the doors
do you understand we'll be all right
here we'll be all right here - someone
comes to rescue us but we'll have to
work together you'll have to help me now
I want you to go in and get some wood so
I can board the place up do you
understand okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's wrong
I wish to tighten this pick up the
biggest ones you can find there this
room looks pretty secure if we have to
we can run in here and board up the
doors won't be long from the station is
back pounding their way in here they're
afraid now the afraid of fire I found
[Music]
feet man's feet fence diner and you know
that's where I found that truck I have
out there there's a radio in the truck I
had jumped in to listen to it when a big
gasoline truck came screaming right
across the road but there must have been
1015 of those things chasing after it
grabbing and holding on
and I didn't see them at first I could
just see that the truck was moving in a
funny way
those things were catching up to it
right across the room slammed on my
brakes to keep from hitting it myself
went right through the guardrail
I guess guess the driver must have cut
off the road into that gas station by
beekman's diner it went right through
the middle boy ripped over a gas pump
and never stopped moving but now it's
like a moving bonfire didn't know if the
truck was going to explode or what still
you're the man screaming
this thing is just backing away from it
I look back at the diner to see if there
was anyone there who can help me that's
when I noticed that the entire place had
been encircled wasn't a sign of life
left except by now there are no more
screams to realize it I was alone with
50 or 60 of those things just standing
there staring at me
I started to drive I just plowed right
through them they didn't move it didn't
run or this stood there staring at me
just wanted to crush them
scattered through the air like bugs we
were riding in the cemetery Johnny and
me Johnny we we came to put a wreath on
my father's grave Johnny and he said can
I have some candy Barbra um we didn't
have any and oh it's hot in here hot and
and he said oh it's late why did we
start so late and I said Johnny if you'd
gotten up earlier we wouldn't be late
Johnny asked me if I were afraid and I
said I'm not afraid Johnny and then this
man started walking up the road he came
slowly and Johnny kept teasing me and
saying he's coming to get you Barbra
and I laughed at him and said Johnny
stop it and then Johnny ran away I went
to this man and I was going to apologize
why don't you just keep called and I
looked up and I said goodie and he
grabbed me I just calm down
Oh Johnny help me and then Johnny came
and he ran and he he fought this man I
got so afraid I ran I ran and Johnny
didn't come we've got we had to wait for
Johnny me we better go up and get him we
have to go out and get Johnny he's out
there please don't you hear me we've got
to go out and get him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because of the obvious threat to untold
numbers of citizens and because of the
crisis which is even now developing this
radio station will remain on the Air day
and night this station and hundreds of
other radio and TV stations throughout
this part of the country are pooling
their resources through an emergency
Network hookup to keep you informed of
all developments at this hour we repeat
these are the facts as there is an
epidemic of mass murder being committed
by a virtual army of unidentified
assassins the murders are taking place
in villages cities rural homes and
suburbs with apparent pattern or reason
for the slayings it seems to be a sudden
general explosion of mass homicide we
have some descriptions of the assassins
eyewitnesses say they are ordinary
looking people some say they appear to
be in a kind of trance others describe
them as being
result at this point there is no really
authentic way for us to say who or what
to look for and guard yourself against
miss shapen monsters reaction of law
enforcement officials is one of complete
bewilderment at this hour
so far we have been unable to determine
that any kind of organized investigation
is underway
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thousands of office and factory workers
are being urged to stay at their places
of employment not to make any attempt to
get to their homes however in spite of
this urging and warning streets and
highways are packed with the safest
course of action at this time
stay
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we just received
word that the president has called a
meeting of his cabinet to deal with the
sudden epidemic of murder which has
seized the eastern third of this nation
the meeting is headed to convene within
the hour
members of the presidential cabinet
confessions of a White House spokesman
in announcing this conference says there
will be an official announcement as soon
as possible following that meeting this
is the latest dispatch just received in
our newsroom latest word also from
national press services in Washington DC
now tells us that the emergency
presidential conference which we've just
mentioned will include high-ranking
scientists from the National Aeronautics
and Space Administration
[Music]
renew
listening have joined their facilities
in an emergency network to bring you
this news as it develops we urge you to
stay tuned to radio and TV and to stay
indoors at all costs late reports
reaching this newsroom tell of
frightened people seeking refuge in
churches and schools and government
buildings demanding shelter and
protection from the wholesale murder
which apparently is engulfing much of
the nation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so far the only descriptions of the only
Clues anyone has of the killer's come
from frightened witnesses understands
these nightmares accounts variously
describe the murderers as ordinary
people messages even monsters trances
tell him seeing victims who look as
though they had been torn apart
ESMA ghastly story began developing two
days ago with
the snowballing in a reign of terror
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
bullets out there in the radio look I
don't know here I'm going upstairs now
if anything should try to break in here
I can hear from up there I'll be down to
take care of everything is all right for
now I'll be back to reinforce the
windows and doors later but you'll be
all right for now okay
okay civil defense officials in
Cumberland have told newsmen that murder
victims show evidence of having been
partially devoured by their murderers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
consistent reports from witnesses to the
affected people who acted as though they
were in a kind of trance were killing
and eating their victims prompted
authorities to examine the bodies of
some of the victims medical authorities
in Cumberland have concluded that in all
cases the killers are eating the flesh
of the people they murdered repeating
this latest bulletin just received
moments ago from Cumberland Maryland
civil defense authorities have told
newsmen that murder victims show
evidence of having been partially
devoured by their murderers medical
examination of victims bodies shows
conclusively that the killers are eating
the flesh of the people they kill and so
this incredible story becomes more
ghastly with each report
it's difficult to imagine such a thing
actually happening but these other
reports we have been receiving and
passing on to you reports which have
been verified as completely as is
possible in this confused situation it
is happening and it would appear that no
one is safe from this wave of
[Music]
murder victims being partially eaten by
their Slayers is true no further details
available at this time I could use some
help
that's the selarón to save this place I
mean you didn't hear the racket how are
we supposed to know what was going on
because there have been those things for
all we know that girl was screaming
surely you must know what a girl
screaming sounds like those things don't
make any noise anybody look it's kind of
hard to hear what's going on down there
we thought we could hear screams but
we're already knew that could have meant
those things were in the house afterward
and you wouldn't come up as hell well if
there were more the racket sounded like
the place was being ripped apart how are
we supposed to know what's going on you
just got through this thing you couldn't
hear from down there now you say it
sounds like the place was being ripped
apart it would be nice if you get your
story straight man oh right now you tell
me I'm not gonna take that kind of a
chance when we got a safe place we luck
into a safe place and you're telling us
we gotta risk our lives just because
somebody might need help huh all right
why don't we settle this mister we came
up okay we're here now I suggest we all
go back downstairs before any of those
things find out we're in here you got
the whole place boarded up I'll be a few
spots upstairs they won't be hard to fix
you are any sane the cellars the safest
place I'm telling you they can't get in
here and I'm telling you those things
turned over our car we were damn lucky
to get away at all now you tell me those
those things can't get through this
lousy pile of wood his wife and kids
downstairs the kids hurt well I still
think we're better off up here we could
strengthen everything up mr. Cooper with
all of us working we can fix this place
up in no time we have everything we need
up here we can take all that stuff
downstairs with us and you're really
crazy you know that you've got a million
windows up here all these windows you're
gonna you're gonna make them strong
enough to keep these things out huh I
told you those things
have any strength I smashed three of
them and pushed another one out the door
did you hear me when I told you they
turned over on a car hell any good five
men can do that that's my point
only there's not going to be five or
even ten there's gonna be twenty thirty
maybe a hundred of those things and as
soon as they know we're here this place
is gonna be crawling with them well if
they're that minute they'll probably
give us wherever we are
look the cellar the cellar there's only
one door right just one door that's all
we have to protect Tom and I fixed it so
it locks and boards from the inside but
up here all these windows why we'd never
know where they were gonna hit us next
you got a point mr. Cooper but down in
the cellar there's no place to run to I
mean if they did get in the back exit
we'd be done for we can get out of here
if we have to and we got windows to see
what's going on outside but then I'm
there with no winners
if a rescue party did come we wouldn't
even know it but the cellar is the
strongest place cellar is a death trap
I don't know these two Cooper I think
he's right you know how many's out there
maybe six or seven you two can do
whatever you like I'm going back down to
the cellar and you better decide cause
I'm gonna board up that door and I'm not
gonna unlock it again no matter what
happens now wait a minute mr. Cooper I'm
not gonna wait I've made my decision now
you make yours
now wait a minute let's think about this
we can make it to the cellar if we have
to and if we do decide to stay down
there we'll need some things from up
here so let's at least consider this a
while you bucked yourself in the cellar
and those things get in the house you've
had it at least up here you have a
fighting chance yeah it looks like about
eight or ten I don't know just more than
that were there a lot out back too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we gotta fix these boards you're crazy
those things are gonna be at every
window and door in this place we've got
to get down into the cellar I'm taking
the girls over here keep your hands up
there and everything else that's up here
too because if I stay up there I'm
fighting for everything up here in the
radio and the food is part of what I'm
fighting for
now if you're going down the cellar dip
the man's insane he's insane please
we've got to have fun down there we've
got right this is your house
we've got a right you going down there
with him well yes or no this is your
last chance no beating around the bush
listen I got a kid down there she she
can't plus I couldn't bring her up here
she can't possibly take all the racket
those those things smashing through the
windows well you're her father if you're
stupid enough to go die in that trap
that's your business however I am NOT
stupid enough to follow you it is tough
for the kid that her old man is so
stupid no forget the hell down in the
cellar you can be the boss down there
I'm boss up here bastards you know I
won't open this door again
I mean it mr. Cooper with your help we
can list my help let him go man his
mind's made up just let him go wait in
it Jimmy come on
you gotta let them get her too huh it's
alright if we stick together man we can
fix it up real good
there there's lots of places we can run
to up here mr. Cooper we'd all be a lot
better off all three of us were working
together hey hey kid
[Music]
he's wrong you know I'm not boxing
myself in down there well we're safe now
it's boarded up tight what about Tom and
Judy they want to stay up there let him
there two other people upstairs man and
a girl we heard screaming yeah but I
didn't know who they were I wasn't about
to take any unnecessary chances
[Music]
is she all right I don't know she feels
warm maybe it's shock where'd you get
the bandage some laundry in a basket I
saw a sheet
let them stay upstairs let them too many
ways those monsters can get in up there
we'll see who's right we'll see when
they come begging me to let them in down
here that's important isn't it what to
be right everybody else to be wrong
what do you mean by that does anyone up
there know why we're being attacked
whatever it is it isn't just happening
here's some kind of mass murder it's
going on everywhere the radio said to
stay inside yell radio upstairs I heard
a news bulletin there's a radio upstairs
and you boarded us in down here I know
what I'm doing what did it say nothing
nothing they don't know anything yet but
there's mass murder everywhere and and
people are supposed to look for a safe
place to hide take the boards off that
door
we are staying down here Helen Harry
that radio is at least some kind of
communication if the authorities know
what's happening with those ten people
for us so they tell us what to do how
are we going to know what's going on if
we lock ourselves in this dungeon
[Music]
we may not enjoy living together but
dying together isn't going to solve
anything those people aren't our enemies
let's come up Tom if Judy would come
downstairs for a few minutes Harry and I
could come upstairs we do it do I have
to look honey nothing's gonna get done
with them down there and us up here do
this for me okay
[Music]
[Music]
I'll take a care of her Helen
she died
why don't you go upstairs now
[Music]
[Music]
her brother was killed hey give me a
hand with this thing I gotta go help
Bennet the television
[Music]
don't be afraid of me I'm Helen Cooper
Harry's wife
this place is ridiculous look at this
there's a million weak spots up here
give me one of those her brother was
killed and they talk about these windows
I can't see a damn thing
there could be 50 million of those
things out there that's how much good
these windows are why don't you do
something to help somebody
I have dragged a couple of those chairs
together there's a socket over here you
better watch this and try to understand
what's going on
I always like on my hands is there
anything I can do if you stay up here
you take orders from me and that
includes leaving the girl alone it's on
it's up there's no sound play with the
rabbit ears reports incredible as they
seem are not the results of mass
hysteria mass hysteria
wave of murder which is sweeping the
eastern third of the nation is being
committed by creatures who feast upon
the flesh of their victims first
eyewitness accounts of this grisly
development came from people who were
understandably frightened and almost
incoherent officials and newsmen at
first discounted there was eye witness
descriptions as being beyond belief
however the reports persisted medical
examinations of some of the victims bore
out the fact that they had been
partially devoured I think we have some
late words are just arriving and
interrupt to bring this to you this is
the latest disclosure in a report from
National Civil Defense headquarters in
Washington it has been established that
persons who have recently died have been
returning to life and committing acts of
murder a widespread investigation of
reports from Funeral Homes morgues &
hospitals has concluded that the
unburied dead are coming back to life
and seeking human victims it's hard for
us here to believe what we're reporting
to you but it does seem to the effect
when this emergency first began radio
and television was advising people to
stay inside behind locked doors for
safety well that situation has now
changed and we're able to report a
definite course of action for you civil
defense machinery has been organized to
provide rescue stations with food
shelter medical treatment and protection
by armed National Guardsmen stay tuned
to the broadcasting stations in your
local area for this list of rescue
stations this list will be repeated
throughout our news coverage look for
the name of the rescue station nearest
you and make your way to that location
as soon as possible so we have that
truck we can get some gas we can get out
of here there's a pump out by the shed I
know that's why I pulled in here but
it's long called this afternoon by the
president since convening this
conference of the presidential cabinet
the FBI the Joint Chiefs of Staff CIA
has not produced any public information
why are space experts being consulted
about an Earthbound emergency so far all
the betting on the answer to that
question centers on the recent Explorer
satellite shot to Venus that satellite
you recall started back to earth but
never got here that's the space vehicle
which orbited Venus and then perp was
purposely destroyed by NASA when
scientists discovered it was carrying a
mysterious high-level radiation with it
could that radiation be somehow
responsible for the wholesale murders
we're now suffering newsman Don Quinn in
Washington has posed those questions our
best move to try to get out of here how
are you gonna get over to that pump look
you're coming from a meeting regarding
the explosion of the Venus probe right
yes yes that was the subject of the
meeting you feel there is a connection
between this and the phenomenon there's
a definite connection a definite
connection otherwise you feel that the
radiation on the Venus probe is enough
to call these because these mutations
there was a very high degree of
radiation stam init uh I'm not sure that
that's certain at all I don't think that
has been a realization that we have at
this time
the radiation is not the cause of the
mutation I can't speak for the entire
military at this time gentlemen disagree
with these gentlemen presently until we
until this is irrefutably proved
everything is being done that can be
done have to hurry for our next meeting
professor you feel that there is a
connection between dr. please I thought
we decided that is this afternoon we
have to try to get out of here he said
the rescue stations are doctors and
medical supplies if we could get Karen
there with us help for the world's
foremost authorities on space science
and technology alert I saw a sign that
said Willard it's only about 17 miles
from here
you know this area you from around here
Judy and I are both from around here we
were on our way up to the lake to go
swimming when Judy had a radio and we
heard the first reports about this so we
knew the old house was here and we came
in and found the lady upstairs dead then
these other people came we went down
into the basement put a bar across the
door and it is pretty strong how can we
possibly get away from here we've got a
sick child two women one woman out of
her hand as we've been the third place
is surrounded under stare a meal for
NASA dr. Grimes your entire staff I know
has been working very hard to find some
solution to these things that are
happening do you have any answers at
this time yes we have some answers but
first let me stress the importance of
seeking medical attention for anyone
who's been injured in any way
we don't know yet what complications
might result from such injuries how bad
as a kid been hurt
look you go down there and tell an adju
D yeah you tell Judy to come up here and
you stay with the kid all right at the
University we had a cadaver cadaver from
which all four limbs had been amputated
sometime early this morning it opened
his eyes and began to move its trunk it
was dead but it opened his eyes and
tried to move they watch upstairs did
she ask for me she had to do everything
I don't understand baby it's mommy I
heard
I'll come back down as soon as I find
out
thank you Judy the body should be
disposed of at once preferably by
cremation well how long after death then
does the body become reactivated it's
only a matter of minutes minutes well
that doesn't give people time to make
any irelia right it doesn't give them
time to make funeral arrangements bodies
must be carried to the street and and
invert they must be burned immediately
soak them with gasoline and burn them
the bereaved will have to forgo the
dubious comforts that a funeral service
will give they're just dead flesh and
dangerous
you can't need to find some bedspreads
or sheets the tear in the small strips
ok is there from cellar here yes we need
some bottles or jars make Molotov
cocktails to hold them off while we try
to escape hey there's a big can of
kerosene down there I'll look for the
bonds there's a big key ring down there
or maybe a key to the gas pump
underneath I'll check you can toss the
cocktails from a window upstairs but
meantime a couple of us can go out and
try to get the guests and come back for
the rest of the people but that'll leave
a door open someplace man that's right
it's better be this door it's closer to
the truck before it all goods and
supplies behind the cellar door while
we're gone the rest of you can holed up
in there I found some fruit jars in the
cellar and there's a key on here that's
labeled for the gas pump out back I'm
not really that used to the truck
I found it abandoned I can handle the
truck no sweat
[Music]
you're it then you'll now go
[Music]
we'll put whatever lumber we find behind
the cellar door you can go upstairs and
toss the cocktails from a window Tom you
and I would have to unboard this door
after you toss the cocktails Russell
back down here in Lock this door it's no
good to board it up because we'll have
to get back in quickly after we get the
gas and get back into the house then
we'll worry about getting everybody into
the truck
let's move indications are that before
this emergency is over they will need
many many more such rescue stations
[Music]
you always have smile for me how can you
smile like that all the time
I mean you have done come on honey we
gotta move
Tom are you sure about the phone the
phone is dead out all you get is a
recorded message if I can only call the
folks they're going to be so worried
about us it'd be all right as soon as we
get to Willard we'll call them they
might even be there I know Tom are you
sure we're doing the right thing Tom
what about getting out of here
yeah well the television said that's the
right thing to do we've got to get to a
rescue station I don't know come on and
you're starting to sound like mr. Cooper
now why do you have to go out there look
I know how to handle that truck and I
can handle the pump then doesn't know
anything about that stuff but we're safe
in here
for how long honey we're safe now but
there's gonna be more and more of those
things I know I know all that listen
remember when we had the big flood
remember how difficult it was for us to
convince you that it was right to leave
remember remember we had to go to
Willard then this isn't a passing thing
honey it's not like just a wind passing
through we've got to do something and
fast
I just don't want you to go out there
that's all hey smile
was it big snarly
[Music]
why just showing you who used it on we
got work to do me and you yeah
[Music]
we're better gonna herd downstairs we
have to go downstairs now Barbra she's
right you have to go downstairs now just
for the long until we get back
then we can all leave Oh we'd like to
leave yes
[Music]
good luck yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is it coming come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this key won't work
[Music]
watch the tart
get away from the pump
[Music]
come on come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you up in those things
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
bhisma three o'clock yet
there's supposed to be another broadcast
at 3 o'clock 10 minutes Oh only 10 more
minutes we don't have very long to wait
we can leave
well we better leave soon it's ten
minutes to three you know anything about
this area at all I mean is Willard the
nearest town I don't know we were just
trying to get to a motel before dark you
say those things turned your car over
you think we can get it back on its
wheels and driving where is it it seems
like we ran forget it
it's at least a mile johnny has the keys
you're gonna carry that child a mile
through that army of things out there I
can carry the kid what's wrong with that
scare one of those things grabbed her
bitter on the arm what's wrong who knows
what kind of disease those things carry
is she conscious barely if you can't
walk she's too weak well one of us could
try to get to the car you're gonna turn
it over by yourself you can't start the
car johnny has the keys you have a car
where where is it won't be able to start
yeah yeah I know but where is it
[Applause]
good lord
[Applause]
[Music]
being monitored closely by scientists
and all the radiation detection stations
at this hour they report the level of
the mysterious radiation continues to
increase steadily so long as this
situation remains government spokesmen
warn that dead bodies will continue to
be transformed into the flesh-eating
ghouls all persons who die during this
crisis from whatever cause will come
back to life to seek human victims
unless their bodies are first disposed
of by cremation our news cameras have
just returned from covering such a
Search and Destroy operation against the
ghouls this one conducted by sheriff
Conan McClellan in Butler County
Pennsylvania so now let's go to that
film report all law enforcement agencies
and the military have been organized to
search out and destroy the marauding
ghouls the survival command center at
the Pentagon has disclosed that a ghoul
can be killed by a shot in the head or a
heavy blow to the skull officials are
quoted as explaining that since the
brain of a ghoul has been activated by
the radiation the plan is kill the brain
and you kill the ghoul chief chief
McClellan how's everything going Oh
things aren't going too bad men are
taking it pretty good you want to get on
the other side of the road over there
chief do you think we'll be able to
defeat these things well we killed 19 of
them today right in this area that was
last three we caught trying to claw
their way into an abandoned shed they
must have thought somebody was in there
there wasn't no we heard him making all
kind of noise we came over and beat him
off blasted him down yeah okay chief if
I were surrounded by six or eight of
these things would I stand a chance with
them well there's no problem if you had
a gun shoot him in a head that's a sure
way to kill him if you don't get
yourself a club or a torch beat them or
burn them they go up pretty easy well
chief McClellan how long do you think it
will take you until you get the
situation under control
well
that's pretty hard to say we don't know
how many of them there are we know when
we find them we can kill them are they
slow-moving chief yeah they're dead
they're all messed up well in time would
you say you ought to be able to wrap
this up in 24 hours well we don't really
know and we know we'll be into it most
of the night probably into the early
morning we're working our way toward
Willard and we'll team up with a
national guard over there and then we'll
be able to give a more definite view
thank you very much chief McClellan this
is bill cardille wic-tv 11 news thank
you Bill for that report official
spokesmen declined to speculate just how
long it may take to kill off all the
flesh-eaters so long as the heavy rain
[Music]
there's a fuse box in the cellar I don't
know I it isn't the fuse the power lines
are down Helen I have to get that gun
haven't you had enough
but two people are dead already on
account of that guy take a look out that
window
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go ahead go ahead you'll understand here
now
get out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey Vince now you want to get about four
or five men and a couple dogs there's a
house over here behind those trees we
want to go check it out
fine just over here bill yeah chief
we're going to stay with it till we meet
up with a National Guard one of the
volunteers you're doing all the work you
take it thank you
we should be wrapped up here about three
or four more hours and we'll probably
get into Willard's end I guess you can
go over there and meet the National
Guard Nick you interested you might want
to come with me
no don't let's check any office see
what's happening all right Steve tell
her we're gonna stay with it and
everything appears to be under control
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they need you down there by the barn if
you met me checked out the house
somebody had a cookout here Vince yeah
sure looks like it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
he says that we get up here Nick Tony
Steve you want to get out in that field
and build me a bonfire
you drag that out of here and throw it
on the fire nothing down here alright go
ahead down and give him a hand let's go
check out the house there's something
there I heard a noise all right Vince
hit him in the head right between the
eyes
[Music]
good shot okay he's dead let's go get
him that's another one for the fire
[Music]
all right send a wagon through
[Applause]
you know dog back off of those things
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
irani like these barges on there
[Music]